hi Rachel hey Abby hi hey you two are so
goodness together oh thank you very much
you know I I love this movie so much
there are so many funny awkward moments
that so many of us I know I can relate
to was there a moment that really stood
out to you while you were filming
oh gosh honestly what stood out to me
the well when I first read the script I
was looking at that first kiss scene and
I was just
I was trying to avoid it for as long as
possible and then it happened and we had
to shoot it from three different angles
so I have to say I've got my first 150
kisses in because we had about 50 takes
each angle so you know got my paycheck
for the day for that
you earned it
I love that Rachel what about you
oh I mean there's so many relatable
moments this is why this is so beloved I
think as a as a piece but um I mean I
really relate to the bra moment you know
going to get your first bra and just how
cringe-worthy that is but it was also
really interesting to be the mom on the
other side and realize oh this was what
my mom was going through that day too
like she didn't know what to do where to
look how to you know
um and I'm so grateful she came with me
and was like whatever we're doing this
let's just get it over with
um and then you look back on it and
you're like thank you know thank you
you know at the end of the day you're
grateful yeah that's nice that you have
that relationship with your mom because
and especially with the relationship
with both your characters in this not
everyone feels comfortable talking to
their parents about these awkward
moments you know right yeah
and I think that's why we can all relate
to this and I I just love that
relationship after doing this movie
Rachel is there a conversation or a
moment that you are not looking forward
to having with your own kids
well right now my son is asking a lot
about death
oh I went through that phase yeah that's
fun
um I just I wasn't ready for it I guess
like I feel like I'm gonna be well I
think I'm Gonna Be Ready for other
conversations but that one just came so
much sooner I thought that would be
after sex it's like it's sex and then
death of my brother's like my favorite
colors are red and black the colors of
blood and death and that's his favorite
thing to say now it's his favorite fact
about himself he's like yeah my favorite
color or red and black
my brother's ten he's five years younger
um and okay I mean yeah he's awesome but
he gets into weird stuff sometimes
so Brothers
exactly right but it is I mean these are
Big topics and now as the parent you're
responsible for telling your kids about
these big things yeah right yeah and I
like I said it just comes so much faster
than you expect I think that's the thing
is you think there you keep them younger
than they are in your mind right and and
they're like going light years past you
and you're like just trying to keep up
here yeah oh I can only imagine
um Abby what is your favorite thing
while you're on set in terms of Rachel
McAdams playing your mom what's the best
part about her playing your mom
oh my God I don't know
um I think we had a lot of Great Moments
uh I have to say what was really really
fun is while we were while we were
shooting or like on the side we we found
this card game called the nomia and I
think that was a real bonding experience
you know you have to shout out facts and
just scream at each other a lot and that
was really fun you know real real
bonding great Icebreaker yeah yeah
getting hoarse screaming at each other
yes have some water on hand when you
play that you're gonna need it it's
intense right okay I've never played
this game but it is now on my list yeah
look it up it's a good one it will
um congratulations on the movie Judy
Bloom saying it's better than her book
that's a big deal oh that's the highest
compliment possible truly we are we're
relieved yeah I bet awesome well thanks
so much thank you thank you take care
bye